first five minutes of this ball game
and they get the switch again if they
want but they can't beat lopez off the
dribble
this is the way lopez played in game two
which was a victory for the bucks after
they lost game one here's mcdonald's
kicking it to the corner
just didn't beat the shot clock and
cappella keeps it alive stripped by low
frames
on the run and stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
what a start for milwaukee at both ends
of the floor they are locked in
defensively here
i'm out call by nate mcgillin this is
the type of defense
and intensity we saw in game two by the
books and that's your center
coming up with a steal and crazy eyes
with the crazy dunk
bobby port is in the bucks rolling
in game two they get 22
pointers that's been a three-point
highlight
of the
[Applause]
just that right foot on the line for a
long two here gets the
friendly bounce here and pfizer forum
[Music]
first to the floor to get the loose ball
and puts it up
and he is an absolute
fan favorite here in milwaukee they've
been chanting
bobby bobby calamari
now 6-6 at the
free-throw line